albert has been a crip since age 12 he's
one of the first generations of the LOS
angeles-based gang a group known as the
original baby gangsters his seniority
puts him near the top of the Crips
national hierarchy here in Lebanon
he runs a criminal syndicate of roughly
50 men Howard American
say our gut
alright guys ready
they compete with a dozen other gangs to
financially exploit the inmates the
Crips rackets include extortion gambling
and drugs well that's the life of a
convict you got to survive in this
institution and basically survive when
you're not free is by all means then and
everybody that your friend is your enemy
you got to eat the gang leader is
constantly on the lookout for new
inmates they offer Albert an easy
opportunity for extortion the Crip
reveals his technique for shaking them
down the guard comes in I'll take him
when they call child I go down into
herself maxine home you going to
challenge he's like your cousin growing
a child and I walked a child with him
let him know I'm there after offering a
friendship and protection then he turns
the screws Albert will take the inmate
into a cell or empty stairwell and
demand payment money gifts or service if
he refuses it gets ugly
I said with aggression with my face
expression and bass not going in with no
shirt on and my blood and my pockets
over here seeing if you know he saw
slapping or just grabbing by stroke
choking for good 10 12 seconds and here
come around
many new inmates don't realize their
prey until it's too late